if you watch my program with any
regularity you probably won't be shocked
to hear me say that I'm against violence
I'm against terrorism I'm against
criminality and vandalism so I have to
call it out no matter who the
perpetrators are and there's a story
that's gotten relatively little coverage
but is extremely disturbing which is
that a self-described anti-fascist and
anarchist showed up at an ice facility
near Seattle Washington fire bombed the
place attempted to burn cars buildings
I'll have the details for you in a
second the man ultimately died after
being shot by police he actually said
that he was motivated by the recent
immigration raids and deportations that
the Trump administration has been
undertaking and the facility in question
had actually had an organized protest
earlier in the day and the fire bomber
showed up after hours very early the
following morning 4:00 or 5:00 a.m.
through incendiary devices lit a car on
fire tried burning down buildings and a
propane tank and generally wreaked havoc
we're talking about a 69 year old and as
I mentioned police ultimately shot him
dead now the same guy was arrested last
year at a protest outside the same
detention center after allegedly jumping
onto a police officer we know the man's
motivations because before he showed up
he wrote a letter to friends calling it
a manifesto saying he was going to quote
take action against the forces of evil
specifically fascism and quote
concentration camps he wrote I am an
Tifa although later he also said he's
not actually affiliated with any
organization so listen when these things
happen it's important for progressive
commentators to talk about it when we
don't we do two things number one we
give the right ammunition to claim that
the left only covers right-wing violence
and to say that we are hypocrites we
don't want that we are not though the
hypocrisy right now is mostly on the
right and we need to keep it that way if
we're against violence
we need to condemn it in all forms no
matter the political orientation now
just as importantly it's important to
talk about these stories be
because it does provide another
opportunity to mention that the
overwhelming majority of politically
motivated violence in the United States
is right-wing period so I know as is
often the case many people on both sides
are going to be angry with me for this
story there will be some on the left who
are angry that I'm even talking about
this incident they will say this was
just a mentally ill guy the fact that he
said he was an anti-fascist or whatever
against Trump's concentration camps he's
really just a mentally ill guy David you
shouldn't even be talking about it there
will be people on the right who will be
angry because they'll say David this is
a story about left-wing violence why are
you making this about right-wing
violence well listen left-wing violence
exists this particular incident is also
being described as either a
suicide-by-cop attempt by people who
knew the man that mental illness was
really the factor here but it doesn't
matter either way this is one incident
at least at the surface level the
radicalization appears to be left-wing
radicalization okay in a country of 340
million people there will be examples of
everything but the bigger numbers point
in really clear directions and it's that
most of the political violence in the
United States comes from the right when
it comes to anti feh and condemning them
this show has never been a show that
placates or embraces these types of
groups I have been completely against
movements that use violence in order to
try to achieve their political goals
number one when it comes specifically to
a group that claims to be anti-fascist
when you say you were against fascism
and this goes now to an Tifa not to this
guy who wasn't even affiliated in any
kind of formal way with these groups
when you claim to be against fascism and
you employ violent authoritarian tactics
to suppress what you see as fascism it's
implicitly contradictory number to
remember and Tifa is tiny how many
people are we even talking about here
this is not how positive change will
come to the United States and I've made
that clear and I don't know that I need
to really try to bolster my credentials
of being against violence that's been
made pretty clear over the last many
many years on the program
number three this particular guy
considered himself an anti-fascist but
made clear he's not part of any group so
this individual was a combination of
someone who yes does appear to have
significant emotional disturbance who
has been radicalized but is also
independent and with access to firearms
which is not something that's been
discussed most of the coverage of this
story which as I mentioned the left
should be covering it I've mostly seen
only the right cover it the right has
not even mentioned the firearms
component if you're going to seriously
talk about what's going on here talk
about the radicalization against fascism
and against Trump's deportation short
that's a part of it talk about mental
illness that's often a part when of any
incident where people are motivated to
do this stuff talk about the guys
affiliation short talk about all of
those things how do you do the story
though without talking about the fact
that this guy had ready easy access to
firearms that in many countries he would
not have had access to you're not
seriously covering the story unless you
also talk about the firearm component so
we on the Left don't have to shy away
from covering these stories anecdotally
people like this are not nearly the
biggest problem that we're dealing with
I completely denounce this person's
actions I completely am against any of
these violent actions by anybody under
the umbrella of anti feh or whatever
group they claim to be a part of no
matter what ideological or political
agreements or disagreements I would have
with anyone on the left right middle
anarchist whatever these are tactics
that I am against full stop period and
the left doesn't need to shy away for it
from it and in particular we don't need
to shy away from it because we are right
on the issues and again most of the
violence if you really want to deal with
political violence in the u.s. you were
Dysport disproportionately dealing with
right-wingers who are the source of that
violence disagree with me many of you
might I'm open to hearing from you
change my mind about anything that I've
said here I'm on twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter a David Pakman show
we have a tremendous tremendous Friday
show for you today and we will take a
quick break and continue right after
this
today's sponsor is Skillshare and I'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to Skillshare when
you click the link underneath this video
skill shares the site that offers over
25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]